climat ton paris saclay 2016 en fait
c'est une initiative conjointe entre
plusieurs partenaires dont qui à
l'université paris saclay ya la
communauté d'agglomération paris saclay
l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris saclay et la climate week
c'est la première édition du climat ton
à paris saclay ça se déroulent en même
temps dans 56 villes partout dans le
monde
tous ces acteurs en fait sont intéressés
pour travailler avec les habitants avec
différents différentes compétences sur
les problématiques de développement
durable de gestion des déchets
de d'énergie tout ce qui est lié en fait
aux modifications climatiques et
l'objectif c'est de réunir plusieurs
participants avec différentes
compétences pour les faire travailler
sur des sujets vraiment liés au
territoire paris 5 mai sur la transition
énergétique pour faire émerger des
projets citoyens et pouvoir les mettre
en place
a posteriori les participants ils
viennent d'horizons divers il ya des
étudiants il ya des enseignants de
l'université paris saclay mais aussi de
paris il ya des habitants aussi qu'ils
ont été invités donc du territoire local
et il ya des entrepreneurs
l'idée c'est vraiment de mixer tout le
monde pour faire émerger une créativité
plus un portable
au final jacques équipe va présenter son
concept au son projet sur une
problématique qui aura été ciblés en
amont l'équipe qui va être vainqueur de
ce concours parce que c'est un challenge
en cure à un jury qui va élire l'équipe
qui aura rempli tous les critères donc
la viabilité du projet le lien avec la
thématique la motivation de l'équipe
elle pourra en fait faire des entretiens
avec les équipes de la communauté
d'agglomération pour mettre en place en
fait la solution qui aura été imaginé
dans les boves